[拍手]
本分はなんかすごく素敵な動き出しても肌が透ける
も your 人動画の日へっ
区下田港でそうですでもちょっと私も芳町か量体のことを直お話しさせていただきます
私は人形町で生まれる入場で育って参って現在に至ってます
私のハーモ米社でデータ等をばも芸者だったものですからそれで3代続いているような
形になっております
このほどを芸者さんっていうのはなんか
なんか積もっ
救っ少なくなってしまって大変なんですけども
まあそれなりに弁当芸能というか昔なりのしきたりというかそういうものを無くさない
ように
今現在いろんなことで
形に行動しております
踊りも好きでゲームとが好きなもんですから
他に行くとこないのでやっぱりここでこうしてあの
いきたいと思ってのとそれからその今芳町という土地は
僕わーさんの時
江戸時代からポーズとつながっておりまして
一度中戦争でなりそうになったところをばの
たちが戦争は感じで帰ってきてから鮮度を引いてくれたもんですから
その上に乗っかって私たち
私の他にもまでおりますがそこでずっとあの
芸者さんとして自分から芳町と言うか了解をなくした組む
ないので一生懸命が頑張っております私だけじゃなく私を支えてくれる若い人たち
お姉さん方がいるので今私もそのようにしてできるんですけども
あのやっぱり人という字は1本できないのでみなさんの支えが
今の私があるのでちっとも私が皆さん偉いとかって言ってくださるんですけどそういう
ことではなくって
ただ釜玉私が今の立場にいるということなんです
ここんとこちょっと考えるのは
なんかすごく人形っていうかそういうのを薄くなってきたかなと思ったりしてるんです
ねあの
何か
出て行く何かするということに対しても
おしゃ木とかありがとうとか
そういう言葉が何かなくなってきているような気がしてならないんです
もう最小限度その言葉だけはなくさなくさないようにしていきたいと思ってるんです
けどもやっぱりみんなもそういう形で
ランカス送っ肩と肩がぶつかっただけでもケンカになるような世の中じゃなく
ごめんなさいっと一言で済むそうするとケンカも何もなくなるというふうに思っており
ますそれで絵馬ここんとこなんかスモークもう
いやな事件ばかり起きるのでまあ何でこんなになるんだろうなぁみたいに思ってます
でもそういうことが一番基礎的な事が無くならないように私もうまく
連投がそういうものをと一緒に
みんなこぞっていきたいと思っているんですけども
はいそれでやっぱりあのタクシーとか何か乗った時はありがとう助かりましたという
言葉それはあのなくさないようにしております
私もあの数少ない中でも芸者さんとして頑張ってこれからも生きたい
思いますよ市長というのは古いん年なのでまた人形町
なんか海外にぜひ遊びにいらしていただけたらありがたいと思いますどうぞよろしくお
願い致します
wni 5こんなポスティングいい
ちゃいけないものがたくさんあるんですよねでもそれがなかなか見つからなくているん
ですけども少しでも
なんだよなんかそういうことなあの忘れないように自分なりに努力していきたいと思っ
ておりますでもあのーそうですねやっぱり
人様の支えがあっていき
ていくということなのでやっぱりそういうことだけ忘れないでやっぱり
頑張って生きて行きたいと思いますのでどうぞよろしくお願い致しまふまず芳町の方に
お出かけくださいませ
姉あんちゃんっ
[拍手]